you are working on an HBO miniseries
about Lewis and Clark and that your
you're working on it with Brad Pitt is
that correct sir yeah that's right when
when we were making Fight Club Brad and
I realized that we had this mutual
fascination with the Lewis and Clark
story and right there's the great book
by Steven Ambrose called undaunted
courage right and we've had people come
at us about the idea of playing Lewis
and Clark even and we both agreed you
just couldn't
this is too epic a story to put into a
single film so we we got the rights to
that book and and we this was right when
HBO was starting to do such a great job
with their long-form things like Band of
Brothers and stuff like that and so we
set it up to make a multi-part
miniseries about the Lewis and Clark
expedition and it's taken a long time
getting it all together but we finally
were ready and we're starting to shoot
at this summer have you cast it
you-know-who's yeah Casey Affleck is
playing great list yeah and a terrific
Belgian actor named Matias show an
artist Blaine Clark and it's it's very
exciting it's a it's a it's we've been
at it for many years trying to put this
together and finally getting it going
Andy and I are available if there's
smaller part no it's funny you say that
though there's a I don't know if you
notice but Sacagawea the famous you know
no I know I wasn't I wasn't I thought
you wanted to meet it I said no no no
but and you know what I was gonna say
yes people don't know this but the
reason she got on the expedition was
they there she had been sold in slavery
to a french-canadian trapper who made
her his wife when she was 17 and
impregnated her right he was in his late
40s or early 50s and was a really good
play that older mudgin Lee guy and he
went on the expedition with them with
her as the translator and he complained
the whole way I know actually no this
character
yeah he's hilarious cuz you read the
journal entries all he does is
yeah he could go whole way about
everything that's the role for me you
doing this summer
I'll be there I'll put on a giant beard
I would play that guy he'd probably ship
it is cold I'll be there I will
single-handedly ruin that project
you